[Music]
time now wait for it
Friday Follies ycs falling off the band
don't understand that I love that
filmmaker Michael Moore sat down with
Stephen Colbert last night to push a new
documentary and he also of course
demonized the president and then he went
a step further joining me to discuss
this and the music that's making young
loiterers cry bad joke is Fox News
contributor New York Times best laying
off of the wheel Wilder series Raymond
Arroyo so Raymond what the heck did two
cheeseburgers say last well Michael
Moore is pushing a new documentary and
he said this about the President and
listen to the way in which he described
the policies of President Trump I am as
civil as any Eagle Scout Catholic altar
boy could be when confronted with the
devil we're not talking about political
differences we're talking about
thousands of children being kidnapped
from their parents and put in jail devil
is kidnapping children and putting them
in jail now people dislike sites people
disagreed with the the drone strikes of
President Obama the black site
deportation Bush and they both separated
families no one ever painted in these
stark violent terms because when you
hear that you think this leader must be
removed and by any means necessary and
this is where more I think crossed a
line here culturally that we all should
be very very wary of watch the only way
that we're going to stop this is
eventually we're all gonna have to put
our bodies on the line you're gonna have
to be willing to do this if Michael
Moore is putting his body on the line
it's gonna be a big line but only at
border wall we don't well this is he
this is a border war lies we could send
Michael Moore to the border and then
only have to race to I think anyway he's
looking good man my problem is this he's
demonizing a leader I don't care which
party it is but then just say put bodies
on the line that has an edge of violence
that I think should worry all of us
Harvard is seems like they have a little
anti-asian bias this is weird a Harvard
student alumni group is suing the
University for its admissions policies
they claim that Harvard is
puts a finger on the scale against Asian
admissions talk about diversity
diversity is the highest value they want
to keep a balance in the student body
and look too many Asians getting at well
an Asian score highest in grades
extracurriculars and in the SAT scores
so they have something they call
personal ratings in the admissions
office at Harvard we'll put up on the
full screen what they this is the marks
against asian-americans they're less
like a blind phul Harvard says less
helpful less courageous less time not as
widely respected and least positive
personalities I don't know where they're
getting this aren't we supposed to not
make generalizations about one group of
people trying to keep them out of the
student body yeah it made me think of
Elaine Chao who remember went after
those protestors on her husband's behalf
this week she looked pretty courageous
and helpful to me I think this is going
to they're gonna win this lawsuit
against Harvard yeah Elaine Chao is
saying this is stay away from my husband
she's tough tiger wife tiger wife all
right now we we have one more topic and
that is Rite Aid Rite Aid oh yeah
they've been trying a new tactic now to
rid their stores of bums vagrants and
hobos can you say that anymore
tell me about well they're turning to
the one who writes the songs that make
the vagrants flee he writes the songs
outside your pharmacy my god Barry
Manilow Suze there's blaring Barry
Manilow Sarah no not dr. Z okay they
blare Barry Manilow and guess what it's
keeping the bums away here's the problem
the neighbors are now complaining some
saying I have a mild migraine because
I'm hearing Manilow from sunup to
sundown and some are complaining on
social media about it like this
another night for Barry Manilow
[Music]
[Applause]
but it may be the right tune at the
wrong time because it is keeping the
vagrants away the the neighbors who
called Rite Aid they're telling them
would you rather panhandlers or man
hello take your pick
now I've been thinking what's the
chemistry that's making this work why is
this repelling vagrants there's music
and that's that here's what I think it
is
he has romantic tune full songs many of
them are based on classical pieces which
people don't realize I think it's so
opposite to the chaotic pulsating
culture that we have that it drives you
and a hundred people away but I'll bet a
lot of people walking into writing kind
of like to bop along ok let's let's be
honest yes Raymond took his college-aged
Milan family came with me once to see
Baron it's a Barry Manilow family had a
great time all right Mandy she came and
she gave without taking and then I
turned her away
one thing is clear landok one thing is
clear looks like we made it